[Aplausos]
te voy a confesar algo y es que yo nunca
soñé con ser youtuber
nunca estuve mis planes hasta
recientemente pero en parte es porque
cuando yo era niño ser youtubers no era
una posibilidad porque el youtube no
existía entonces mi sueño era un poquito
más anticuado
yo quería vender un montón de discos
salir el en ti y casarme con avril
lavigne
obviamente ese sueño era un poquito
infantil
y estaba inspirado por gente que era
mayor que yo que creció en una época
diferente a la mía en circunstancias
totalmente diferentes a las mías
entonces pasaron los años y pues ya
nadie compra discos y no pasa música y
avril lavigne y se casó con el cantante
de micro park una gran decepción para
todo el mundo yo sé pero
pero bueno yo terminé superando a abril
a mí
terminé dedicándome a lo que me gusta
hacer pero no de la manera que yo
hubiera podido predecir
y lo importante aquí es la idea de qué
realmente yo hice parte del proceso de
crear un ambiente en el que es posible
vivir de hacer vídeos para internet
sobre música que si no haya preguntado
en el 2006 que opinaba eso él ha pensado
que estaban locos pero bueno pasó
y bueno les explico cómo fue todo ese
proceso pero primero quiero hacer la
pregunta que hay que responder ahora
como una pregunta es cómo espera que
ustedes vivir en el futuro de lo que les
gusta hacer
en un mundo ideal
sería súper normal que un adolescente
está decidiendo qué es lo que va a hacer
por el resto de su vida es una decisión
pequeña
que se decía para estudiar música o cine
y hacer cómics cualquier tipo de cosa
creativa no le generaría un ataque de
un ataque de ansiedad a los padres
no sería no sería como que mi hijito
tiene que hacer algo que valga la pena
tienen que estudiar algo que haga dinero
algo que le dé de comer
no sería normal
bueno sería normal pero ese mundo sigue
pareciendo como súper
inalcanzable parece una utopía parece
imposible y pues lo que yo vengo a decir
hoy es que este mundo es muchísimo más
interesante mucho más posible de lo que
lo que imaginamos
y les voy a explicar cómo como hacer
este mundo positivas están
pero primero vamos a hablar de los
problemas
yo hablar de los problemas desde el
punto de vista de la música que es el
mundo que yo mejor conozco
y bueno la realidad es que ningún músico
hoy en día vive de la música que hace
ninguno
por ejemplo el spotify por reproducción
se le paga al artista entre 0.006
centavos de dólar y 0.00 84 centavos de
dólar y generalmente esta miseria tiene
que ser repartida entre un montón de
gente entonces los únicos que pueden
hacer dinero de eso son las grandes
cristianas
tienen en su catálogo miles y miles de
canciones entonces esto nos llevaría a
pensar que bueno todos los músicos
tendrán que hacer dinero de los
conciertos pero para hacer dinero de los
conciertos hay que hacer un montón de
conciertos o sea que toca irse de gira
por muchísimas ciudades
y la realidad es que irse de gira es
carísimo super caro de hecho se estima
que
solamente los artistas que se están en
el top de los 40 más escuchados pueden
hacer dinero de las giras lo que
significa que el resto de los mortales
tienen que sentirse afortunados si su
gira no los dejó en una bancarrota
absoluta
entonces yo he pasado muchísimo tiempo
de hecho toda mi vida pensando en cómo
crear que hay que cambiar el mundo para
crear un sistema en el que sea posible
vivir de el arte
entonces el sistema que tenemos
actualmente obliga a los músicos
monetizar su arte utilizando publicidad
nos
a promocionar productos o marcas y ese
tipo de cosas
lo que los mete en un mercado muy
similar al de los influencers de
internet
y esto nos lleva a que el mundo del arte
y el mundo de la publicidad
cada vez se unan más hasta el punto que
ella cada vez son más la misma cosa
y esto a mí me parece un sistema
terrible parece funesto
parece o respiran té porque imagínense
un grupo de fans
que aman la música de un artista y todo
lo que cualquier tipo de arte queda un
artista es muy gratificante para sus
vidas entonces quieren asegurarse de que
lo que crea este artista
siga existiendo y que siga creando la
única ruta que les queda
es comprar un producto que vende una
presa que le paga a la artista por
proporcionar ese producto para mí esto
no tiene sentido
tiene para nada sentido además
imagínense una banda super rebelde
transgresora crítica antisistema
como rise against the machine
tratando sobre el este en este modelo
como que no pega para nada
además porque el arte termina siendo
increíblemente comprometida al tener que
ser abierta de ser friendly qué es lo
que pasa un montón no sólo en la música
sino también en youtube
entonces si es terrible entonces
toda la vida estaba pensando que tenemos
que hacer para cambiar
el sistema para que sea posible vivir de
lo que aún no le gusta hacer para sobre
todo si no escribir creativo que tenemos
que cambiar para vivir que sea normal
vivir de de arte o de cualquier cosa que
sea como creación
y que eso no esté solamente destinado a
un grupo súper pequeño de superestrellas
ultra famosas multimillonarias
realmente lo más posible es que tuvieron
muchísima suerte y no son más que una
probabilidad de estadística
y me di cuenta de que el cambio que
tenemos que hacer realmente no es tan
loco
en realidad lo que tenemos que hacer es
cambiar nuestra perspectiva
cambiar ponernos todos de acuerdo y
cambiar nuestra manera en la que nos
relacionamos con el arte
o sea que realmente el cambio es
educativo es de educación lo que cambiar
realmente ningún sistema nada que poner
de acuerdo
entonces en vez de
pensar que cuando estamos pagando por
arte por algún tipo de arte
nos vemos como un individuo que está
consumiendo un producto artístico
tendríamos que pensar los más como
alguien que está siendo parte de la
creación de ese producto artístico
porque
pues si realmente la arte necesita
presupuesto es como cuando en una
película hay un productor ejecutivo que
se encarga de encontrar financiación
para la película y todo ese tipo de
cosas
y esto me llevó una idea muy bonita que
me inspira un montón que llevo muchos
años pensando y es que todos creamos el
arte que consumimos
todos creamos el ángel y consumimos
esa idea me
explica me encanta
entonces en un mundo ideal regresando al
mundo ideal
sería normal que un joven
que es talentoso y es artista empieza a
experimentar y crear arte
esto haría que consiga unos cuantos fans
no se trata de ser una superestrella
consigue unos cuantos fans los cuales
tienen el interés de que esta persona
continúa creando arte
porque lo que hace tiene un impacto muy
positivo en sus vidas entonces deciden
pagarle pero no fue la mentalidad de
pagar por un producto sino pagar por un
servicio en la misma manera en la que
en ciertas ciudades del mundo la gente
paga el tiquete del tren o etiqueta del
metro a pesar de que en la estación no
hay autor ni que determinada revisando
los plastic el que es lo que es pues en
colombia será súper alienígena pero
sucede esto llevaría a que el artista
eventualmente
puede dedicarle más tiempo a su arte
eventualmente podrá renunciar a su
trabajo de mcdonald's podrá estudiar un
montón ser muchísimo mejor
esto ganará muchos más fans que le darán
más dinero entonces eventualmente podrá
contratar a gente que le ayude su arte
tendrá muchísimo más presupuesto
entonces la producción mejorará etcétera
etcétera terminará creciendo hasta el
punto que finalmente crea su gran obra
maestra
y esta gran obra maestra inspirará a los
fans que lo apoyaron en el principio a
seguir sus pasos
a crear cosas
y se repetirá la misma historia una y
otra y otra y otra vez que se creara un
ambiente en el que el arte florece
y habrá un montón de mozart caminando
por la calle
esta es comodidad sería hermoso pero lo
más bonito de todo eso es que todo el
mundo se habría hizo parte del proceso
de crear toda esa arte
fabulosa me parece increíblemente gusto
pero esta idea que me parece súper
bonita sigue pareciéndome super utópica
súper
inalcanzable
pero realmente se lo pensamos todavía
que cambiar mucho saludables que crear
una nueva gran tecnología super avanzada
no habría que lograr la singularidad
tecnológica no habría que cambiar el
sistema económico no habría que destruir
todas las instituciones quemarlas y
volver las cenizas no habría que hacer
una gran revolución
entonces porque sigue pareciendo mental
difícil que eso suceda y realmente es
por
como les dije una situación de educación
porque estamos super acostumbrados a qué
nosotros cuando pagamos por algo estamos
pagando por algún tipo de exclusividad
por obtener
algo que se vuelve a nuestra propiedad
entonces esto nos lleva a pensar en para
qué voy a pagar por algo que es gratis
que está gratis en el internet no tiene
mucho sentido la economía si
económicamente no tiene mucho sentido
pero que está poco peor podemos pensar
tener una sociedad que solamente piensa
con sentido económico sino también
cultural social y todo ese tipo de cosas
entonces tenemos una mentalidad que no
me parece que es muy del siglo 20
por qué
estamos acostumbrados a que todo el
mundo trate a las obras de arte como
productos que se pueden comprar y vender
hasta ahora es la mentalidad que tenemos
el problema con eso es que estamos en el
2019 y la mayoría o si no muchos tipos
de arte y en especial la música no se
puede tratar como un producto porque no
se pueden comprar ni vender porque ya
está todo en el internet entonces la
solución que hemos encontrado para ese
problema ha sido tratar a los artistas
como un producto que compran empresas
para publicitar sus productos
entonces teniendo toda la tecnología que
tenemos hoy en día porque lo vemos a más
artistas viviendo directamente el dinero
que le pagan sus fans si ya está todas
están todo el tipo de fraude zombi
todas las plataformas online ese tipo de
cosas porque pues para qué voy a pagar
por algo que igual está gratis en el
internet
no
entonces les voy a contar una historia
que tiene mucho que ver con esto y este
cuando yo era adolescente
youtube estaba en la prehistoria
descubrí a este tipo que se llama jack
conti que tenía como 22 años 21 años
algo así en la casa de los papás en un
cuarto super pequeño completamente ya
los instrumentos y como con dos
micrófonos y con solo eso y un
computador hacía música impresionante
esa increíble fascinante y a mí me
inspiró sí me llegó muchísimo entonces
que hice yo empecé a pagar por su música
compré todos sus discos
la recomendaba su música a todos mis
amigos los cuales eventualmente también
muchos de ellos compraban su música o la
compraba su música pero le daban dinero
de ciertas formas que él encontraba para
monetizar puntos que entre muchos fans
logramos que ya con ti viviera de la
música
eventualmente este tipo termino
creciendo mejorando y
compro una casa con un estudio muchísimo
más elaborado se volvió mucho más
exitoso pero luego se dio cuenta de lo
que les estaba hablando que la
publicidad del internet y el streaming
son increíblemente injustos con los
artistas entonces él creó una plataforma
web en la que los fans podían mantener
al artista
digamos con una mensualidad dando como 1
o 2 dólares entre todos y el artista
podía terminar viviendo de lo que hacía
y bueno pasaron los años y yo me volví
youtuber y me terminé dando cuenta de lo
mismo de lo injusto que era la
publicidad del internet que los
creadores de contenido
con lo poco que paga el stream y todo
ese tipo de cosas y terminé usando la
plataforma que él creó para poder
monetizar mi trabajo
entonces terminé viviendo yo puedo decir
que vivo gracias al dinero que recibo de
los fans que me mantienen a través de
esa plataforma
y es tabú lo sé pero eso me lleva a
pensar que siempre
todos los fans que apoyamos
y así entre todos los stands que
apoyamos a jacques con ti para que
pudiera vivir de lo que hacen para
eventualmente crear patrios si no lo
hubiéramos hecho él no hubiera creado
patrios hubiera tenido que dedicará a
cualquier otra profesión y yo no hubiera
podido vivir de lo que actualmente hago
probablemente estaría haciendo otra cosa
entonces eso significa para mí que yo
hice parte de crear un ambiente en el
que es posible vivir de crear vídeos
para internet sobre música
y eso me parece muy bonito me parece
fabuloso entonces regresando a la
pregunta que dice al principio de que
van a vivir ustedes en el futuro van a
hacer lo que les gusta hacer y si
quieren hacer eso yo creo que este
cambio perspectiva que yo estoy
proponiendo me recuerda muchísimo a una
frase de jaime garzón
en el que decía que el problema de los
colombianos es que no tenemos conciencia
colectiva tenemos una posición cómoda e
individual ante la vida el problema soy
yo me salgo yo y al resto fría y yo sé
entonces que no estamos con esta
historia que siempre se cuenta de la
persona que trabajó un montón toda su
vida para lograr sus sueños y todo ese
tipo de cosas yo creo que no se trata
tanto de cumplir mi sueño
porque el éxito individual depende
muchísimo del éxito colectivo son las
sociedades más exitosas de otras fuerzas
está el exitoso es como súper obvio y
los colombianos no somos así entonces yo
creo
que si uno va a intentar vivir su sueño
o crear su sueño parte de la
responsabilidad está en crear un mundo
ayudar a crear un mundo en el que
cumplir ese sueño sea normal
porque si seguimos con ese cuento de
tratar de ser uno de los pocos
afortunados superestrellas
multimillonarios realmente estamos
apuntando a tratar de ser parte de una
improbabilidad estadística porque toda
esta gente todo muchísima suerte y no
importa cuánto trabajes muchísima gente
no lo va a lograr
porque también se trata de suerte
entonces
seguir bien esa cosa
se trata de dejarle el futuro de uno a
la suerte y estable me parece un pésimo
plan
muy pésimo claro entonces lo que yo
propongo es todo lo contrario y por eso
yo digo que pagar por arte es crear a
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]